Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here!
If you've already watched my videos about
the scenes and characters that were cut from
Zootopia, you'll know there was loads of stuff
that didn't make it into the final movie.
But before Zootopia's filmmakers decided to
tell the story we know and love of rookie
bunny cop Judy and scam-artist fox Nick, they
had a whole host of ideas which would have
taken the movie in completely different directions.
Yes, during the many years that Zootopia took
to develop, there were many interesting stories
the filmmakers considered which never ended
up getting made.
And that's exactly what I'm going to look
at in this video: the untold stories we never
got to see in Zootopia!
Just before I delve into those, I've got a
cool pair of Disney books to give away from
my friends at DK.
One lucky winner will receive both Zootropolis:
The Essential Guide and also Frozen: The Enchanted
Guide, each of which has some lovely images
and fun facts.
For a chance to win, all you have to do is
subscribe and leave a comment about Zootopia
on this video.
The road to making the Zootopia movie that
we know and love today started with a number
of ideas which director Byron Howard proposed
to Disney's chief creative officer John Lasseter.
For example, there was a pitch to adapt Alexandre
Dumas' classic novel The Three Musketeers
with mice in the starring roles.
What the ideas that Byron Howard pitched had
in common was that they all involved walking,
talking animals who wore clothes.
In fact, both Byron Howard and John Lasseter
shared a love of these types of animation
with the Disney classic Robin Hood being a
particular inspiration for Howard.
"The Island of Doctor Meow" was another story
that was considered by the filmmakers.
This story featured a 6-foot tall mad scientist
cat that possessed a savage serum which could
transform children into animals.
The concept was pitched as a Roger Corman
1960s style B movie with the title and story
drawing inspiration from the science fiction
novel The Island of Dr Moreau by H.G. Wells
in which Dr Moreau, who lives on an island,
creates human-like creatures by experimenting
on animals.
There was also a Guardians of the Galaxy-style
movie pitched called Pug: The Bounty Hunter.
The story was set in outer space and was about
a team of animals hunting for other animals
in space.
After considering those stories, Howard said
that Lasseter loved the ideas and wanted to
combine "the quirky quality of the 1960s world
[with] the animal characters from the space
pug concept" which led Howard to develop his
next concept: a spy movie called Savage Seas.
Savage Seas was planned as a spoof of James
Bond and starred a jackrabbit spy called Jack
Savage who worked at a place like MI6 where
he had a tiny mouse boss, a bit like Judy
Dench.
The movie's first act was set in an animal
city which Jack Savage left for the South
Seas in the second act.
Byron Howard even had titles ready for a whole
series of related movies such as Savage Earth,
The Savage Land and The Savage Times, however
what he found was that people weren't so keen
on the spy element but wanted to see more
of the animal city from the first act.
It was at this point that Howard decided to
set the whole movie in the animal city, keeping
the bunny character and adding a fox as he
felt it would "make a great buddy dynamic
[… as] foxes are natural predators of rabbits."
Once the filmmakers decided to focus the film
on the animal city of Zootopia, the idea was
then developed with a much darker story than
the movie we know today and it centred around
the character of Nick Wilde as the lead.
In this early story, there was a much more
overt level of prejudice from the prey population
against the minority predator population who
were forced to wear tame collars.
The film had a dystopian feel about it, with
the tame collars acting to control predators
by shocking them whenever they became excited
or violent.
One particular sub-story involved Nick setting
up a secret amusement park called Wild Times
just for predators where they would be able
to remove their tame collars and indulge some
of their natural instincts without being electro-shocked.
And if you'd like know more about the designs
for Wild Times, I talk about that in my video
about Zootopia's deleted scenes which you
can click here to watch.
In this version of the movie, Judy was also
a less sympathetic character who initially
supported the collaring of predators.
She was a tough police officer who chased
after Nick when he escaped from the ZPD after
being put in prison.
By the way in the final film, this chase was
replaced with Judy chasing Weaselton through
Little Rodentia.
Eventually Judy came to realise the harsh
truth about the taming collar when she secretly
witnessed a taming party for Koslov's son
Morris, a ceremony in which the 5-year old
polar bear cub receives a taming collar for
the first time and as he gets excited he also
gets shocked by the collar for the first time.
And it was after screenings with the Disney
story trust and later at Pixar that the filmmakers
realised that although the story was interesting,
Zootopia was just too dark a place for the
audience to like.
This realisation came late in 2014 with the
film due out early 2016, which meant the filmmakers
had little over a year to change course.
They threw out the tame collar concept and
made Judy the lead character.
The story of prejudice was still told but
in a much less overt way and through the eyes
of Judy experiencing stereotypes as she worked
the case of the missing otter, later discovering
her own bias as well.
So guys, what do you think about those unused
stories and do you think we could see any
of the ideas or characters adapted and re-used
in a Zootopia sequel?
I'd love to hear what you've got to say in
the comments below.
And don't forget to subscribe and comment
for your chance to win this cool pair of Zootopia
and Frozen books.
For bonus ways to enter the giveaway, check
out the Gleam link in the video description
below.
If you enjoyed this video, take a look at
my other videos explaining all the deleted
scenes and rejected concepts from Zootopia
and 25 things you didn't know about the making
of the movie, and also coming shortly I'll
have a new Zootopia video on all the easter
eggs and hidden mickeys you missed in the
movie.
There's links to them all right here in my
full Zootopia video playlist.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!